some
may describe it as a constitutional
earthquake as we feel the reverberations
of what has happened
we now automatically have a new king
and it's literally been confirmed in the
last few moments that the new king will
be known as king charles iii
now
at home you might be thinking well of
course he would be but actually when it
comes to a change
in reign the new sovereign is able to
choose a different name and of course
we've seen that throughout history so
instead of being king charles he could
have chosen any of his other names which
are philip arthur or george however we
now know that he will be king charles
iii he also takes on other titles so
head of the commonwealth
commander-in-chief of the armed forces
supreme governor of the church of
england
so we have the constitutional change we
have the change in
head of state
but i think what we're also going to see
and i think you're already probably
seeing there at buckingham palace you
will have a greater sense of this
is
a sense that people want to come
together
a collective sense of shock
and mourning it was after all only
two days ago that we saw her still
carrying out her constitutional duties
and as liz trust said in her speech
there are going to be difficult days
ahead where
communities will come together
just as we have done right throughout
her reign to mark those milestone
moments to
pay our respects to
what was a life devoted to service
indeed rihanna thank you for that and i
i would echo
those thoughts in
terms of what people here
are coming to witness and to experience
there's
a huge sense
obviously and clearly of the the end of
an era but also
a little bit of trepidation about what
lies ahead we know that we are in
very difficult times both nationally and
internationally and at this very moment
the rock
as these trusts referred to at the very
spirits of great britain the rock upon
which modern britain was built
has passed
and in just one
short week we have
had the changing of a prime minister now
the
passing of our longest-serving
head of state the rock upon which
britain was built um alastair bruce our
rule commentator
joins me now and um
alastair just on that confirmation now
that um
the king will be king charles
iii and um
camilla queen consort
yes it's a
moment of continuity and a moment of
great sadness
i think for
a nation recognizing that the queen is
now dead
it must be a great shot for the new king
that instantaneously while he
fathoms the loss of his mother
there will be red boxes to be dealt with
there will be the work that the queen
didn't quite finish yesterday
and he must now
continue the function of government as
head of state
immediately
and that process and continuity of
playing the role as monarch
is one where everybody now will look to
king charles iii for decisions on
everything
all the
needs and requirements of the days ahead
will be placed for him to make decisions
on and it is a very busy changing and
the queen referred to it herself when
her father died
back in 1952 that suddenly everybody
looked to her
and she didn't necessarily feel prepared
for it and yet
in her 71st year as monarch she became
so
comfortably adept and with that glinting
eye
when she was waiting for the arrival of
her
15th prime minister in the drawing room
of balmoral castle she wanted to make
photographer waiting
feel at ease and made a charming comment
to him
and i think that's always been the
nature of how she's done this role
is she's
always managed to put herself last
and to approach it with great humility
and she's given that torch
now to the new king who must take on so
much and yet at the same time at this
moment with
his brothers and sister and other
members of the family are recognizing
the loss of their second parent and
somebody sent a message to me now that
you know
lots of people feel they've lost a
parent
and that is the nature of monarchy it
reminds us because we get to know
the monarch almost as though she's a
personal friend
and when she goes
it's like losing
somebody and it echoes a loss in one's
own family and i think that those people
gathering now outside buckingham palace
each of them with their own personal
thoughts
they've come for myriad reasons
and a head of state has to encompass
myriad people with myriad thoughts
and elizabeth ii did that and now the
new king must take on that
responsibility